The Joe Rogan Experience by the way
money might be fake now money might be
falling apart right oh yeah how many
banks have collapsed now wait it's
happening today I don't know I was
trying to follow up how many banks have
collapsed it's at least two correct
there's at least two it might have been
three and I don't know what happened
today with the I was on a plane with the
guy who's talking about this yesterday
yeah so it's so the Silicon Valley one
collapsed right yeah and so a bunch of
Silicon Valley yeah this is like 2008
all over again I don't know see this is
part of the problem with being
financially ignorant which is I am I
don't know and also being friends with
Alex Jones which I am which the [__] so
I can [__] I get all these videos
perfect prepare yourselves at the end of
the world I'm like oh no Alex why are
you freaking me out
oh
I uh yeah I I saw I was on a plane next
week yesterday and said that today's a
big day that it's it's coming down with
everyone's gonna [__] doubt if the
[__] thing collapse where we get
bailed out well apparently there was a
big uh run on the banks today too and
people were showing up at the banks
trying to withdraw money
which scares the [__] out of people when
that kind of stuff happens that's how
Hitler became [__]
prime minister whatever dictator is he
[__] I've been watching this thing
how to make a dictator on uh Netflix
have you seen it oh it's [__] awesome
I'm so obsessed with history podcasts
and history dictators and whatnot do you
know who turkmen boss she is no are you
Joe this is the most fascinating [__]
guy in history right so Turkmenistan I
think is the name of the country was
part of the USSR and when the USSR
collapsed
he got it this this guy who was just a
premier and worked you know he got the
whole country and he went around and
changed rules like [__] crazy he was
a dictator but he was like he added
months so that he didn't get old faster
[Laughter]
change the names of the month I mean he
was a [__] lunatician he said you
know what he goes you know what here's
the problem
people old people are losing their teeth
because they're not eating enough bones
and they're like bones he goes you ever
see a dog with missing teeth no cause
they eat bones so everyone needs to
start eating bones does that guy makes
sense turkmen bossy I I have this
podcast that I listen to It's called the
dictators and it is one of the most that
is that one podcast is the most
fascinating but I get I'm obsessed man I
listen to Hitler Stalin somebody was
talking about the how to make a dictator
um documentary on Netflix the other day
was it I think it was on the podcast it
might just been a conversation I was
having was it on the podcast who was it
do you remember but they were saying
like you might you're literally like
putting up a guidebook on how to become
a dictator like people could watch it
and figure out how it's done and then
replicate it it's identical by the way
to how to get famous
I missed the [__] exact same thing
you'd be shocked wow yeah I wouldn't be
shocked though right because a lot of
famous people become like dictators
that's what I thought yeah this
definition oh he's a he's a history oh
he's a real guy like he's a history guy
we used to do history hyenas with
Giannis yeah that was fun yeah
yeah history is fascinating when you
think that it'll never repeat itself
again
you know like oh that'll never happen
again like I just think that about war
oh we're done with that you know and now
look
dude and the the bank thing is [__]
so what is exactly happening is this
something we need to be concerned about
this I watched the news yesterday to
find out the news said no do not worry
oh well then I'm worried now I'm [__]
worried cause they've been wrong about
everything these [__] my uncle called
me on in 2008 when uh when the housing
crisis collapsed and he was he was
[__] terrified my uncle's one of the
smartest dudes I know and he was like
this is going to be real bad
there was a um house that I used to live
in in the next door to me there was a
lot that um this guy had bought and he
was planning forever to build his dream
house it was a nice lot and had a good
view it was beautiful
and so uh I would go out there
in like two it was like 2009 I would go
out there and there's this old guy and
he would just be raking
and uh I would see him I'd wave to him
and then one day I just said let me go
just go talk to that dude see what's
what's going on because it was you know
are you gonna build like what's
happening he goes
I was gonna but I lost everything
because that uh the 2008 thing I lost
everything I had plans I had a house
and so I'm just sitting there with this
dude who's probably at the time 70 75.
this is the last years of his life and
he's just raking
this plot of land that was going to be
the place for his dream house before the
2008 collapse
he just realized like man the real
victims of all that Financial malarkey
the real victims of all that [__]
corruption and deregulation and all the
chaos that led to so many people losing
their houses so many people losing all
their money this [__] God just raking
his thing made me so sad
too Dylan Tim Dylan did that to him Tim
Dylan Tim Dylan there's so many people
ah what else I gotta do if it wasn't me
it would be somebody else
they were gonna blow it on pills and
women anyway
he's